germany is fame for its autobahns but
today it's about good sense not speed
for the 15th time readers of two popular
german magazines have chosen their most
sensible cars of the year
publisher
defines a sensible car as one that's
economical and safe it uses less fuel
but is still fun to drive
the winner in the compact class is the
opel corsa when it comes to smaller and
compact cars buyers are particularly
fussy
they want a car that's extremely fuel
efficient and yet spacious and
state-of-the-art when it comes to safety
opel's new corsa lives up to all those
expectations the newly developed
gasoline engines offer high performance
and a smoothness normally associated
with cars boasting more than its three
cylinders
marketing director tina mila praises the
course's interior design and a vast
range of driver assists rivaling top of
the range cars they include a blind spot
monitor lane departure alert collision
warning system and much much more
the most sensible sedan for readers was
the vw passat
it offers the very latest headlights
assistance and entertainment systems
should the driver stop responding for
example in a medical emergency the car
automatically comes to a stop
even with the added technology the new
passat has shed 85 kilograms saving on
fuel as well
a new plug-in hybrid drive has been
announced for the summer which can power
the passat gte up to 50 kilometers on
electric power alone
top dog among station wagons is another
vw the golf sports van with its roomy
variable interior combined with the
compact design of a vw golf
the sports van is only marginally longer
than the regular model
inside is so spacious that it can easily
accommodate a family of four and all
their holiday luggage
a minister also graced the awards event
as a guest speaker
he cites the enormous challenges facing
the automotive industry for one the
world is moving away from fossil energy
sources and fuels for another production
sites are relocating with asia growing
stronger and the markets are shifting
south america and above all africa are
entering the arena
but what it comes down to is that
people's behavior is changing young
people in particular crave mobility
while the growing ranks of older people
in society have different needs these
are great challenges that the automotive
industry has to respond to
the award for innovation went to the
sunfire company for its pioneering
development and fuel technology where
gasoline can be produced without crude
oil
the process itself is not innovative
explains co-founder and cto christian
van oozhausen it's the use of
electrolysis and steam instead of water
to achieve 70 percent efficiency the
highest so far sunfire hopes to use it
in industry
the sensible cars awards do not feature
exotic niche products it's about the
winning combination of fuel efficiency
safety and nice prices